so for the last six months I've been
baffled looking at startups looking at
the client work that we do here at
vaynermedia from other agencies and the
brands have done competitive work when
of auditing things looking at new
startups how many people still don't
design their websites for their
experiences for the mobile web or not
even thinking about building mobile apps
this whole notion of mobile first this
is not something I've owned it's not
something that I claimed this has been
around for a while but yesterday and the
consumer habits on mobile studies that
came out a fun little stat came out that
made me really decide was time to make
just one video so once and for all
in 2013 we all realized that mobile this
thing is the thing that you need to be
thinking about in your business whether
you sell tires soda water and whatever
you do if you're a lawyer you need to be
thinking mobile first second and 69
hence the stat 9% of people admitted to
in this study to using their mobile
device during sex having such boring sex
that they're checking score or maybe
doing something else but 9% of people
admitted to using a mobile device during
sex 19% of people admitted to using a
mobile device in church and 55% admitted
to using a phone while driving so let's
remember admitted which means 9% - and
sex is 18% 15% in church is probably 30
40 - 50 % and 55% of driving is probably
99.7% if you are not story telling on
the mobile device first and more
importantly as a marketing business
person if you're not thinking about how
to tell your story on a mobile device
first you are going to lose